moi je suis extrêmement choqué par ce
texte entend comme de gauche communistes
en tant que citoyen français je suis
choquée dvd propos de ministres sur le
benchmarking sur le shopping de l'asile
rappelons nous quand même que ce sont
des hommes et des femmes qui fuient les
guerres et les misères et ce sont des
hommes et des femmes comme nous je suis
choqué par ce suivi citoyens français et
que sur le fronton de nos mairies a
écrit liberté égalité et fraternité je
crois que ça c'est un ciment je suis
choquée parce que le droit d'asile
ces garanties dans notre constitution et
par la convention de genève sur l'asile
en 1951 je suis choquée parce que pour
la première fois dans notre pays on
regroupe asile et immigration
même nicolas sarkozy à qui on doit quand
même le débat sur l'identité nationale
et dont on ne peut pas dire que ce soit
un proche de ses idées n'avait même pas
osé faire ça donc honnêtement je suis
choquée parce qu'en plus on court
derrière l'extrême droite
une course à l'échalote on parle ou plus
bas instincts et non pas l'intellect
parce que si on parlait à l'intellect
des gens ont leur dirai qu'il faut
accueillir dignement des ces personnes
et ces gens qui fuient la guerre et la
misère
il faut leur dire que 97% des gens qui
se réfugient le fond d'abord dans leur
pays et que nous accueillons en europe
que 3% des réfugiés il faut leur dire
surtout qu'ils aient défis devant nous
d'humanité
la banque mondiale dont peut pas accuser
qu'elle soit communiste vient de rendre
un rapport au mois de mars et le 10 148
millions de personnes vont être réfugiés
climatiques à l'horizon 2050
148 millions donc nous allons bien avoir
un problème d'humanité à traiter pour
faire société commune et ça il faut
parler à l'intellect et pas au plus bas
instincts et d'ailleurs là on pourra pas
dire l'extrême droite pour agiter
renvoyer les chez eux renvoyés chez eux
mais ou parce qu'ils n'auront plus taire
puisque tout sera submergée par les eaux
et donc vous voyez bien on est un défi
d'humanité de monde et donc ça ça répond
à une course à l'échalote à extrême
droite c'est un jeu très dangereux parce
que l'extrême droite partout en europe
progresse en ad'ailleurs l'extrême
droite au pouvoir en italie donc ce
qu'on est en train de faire là n'est pas
un jouet c'est très dangereux ce qu'ils
sont en train de faire est-ce que vous